[Musique]
l'innovation en fait ce sont les
industries et les emplois de demain et
le rang de la france à l'échelle
internationale c'est aussi un moyen de
garder nos cerveaux de de stimuler les
appétits chez nos jeunes gens qui sont
en formation pour leur dire que s'ils
s'embarquent dans des projets
d'entreprises innovantes dans des
projets de recherche d'excellence et
bien ils auront dans leur propre pays un
écosystème public qui les soutiendra
mais aussi ensuite toute une chaîne
d'acteurs privés qui seront capables de
les aider à grandir
je crois que nous avons en france
aujourd'hui de vrais potentiels
en termes de recherche de recherche
fondamentale de recherche appliquée et
cela ne se traduit pas autant qu'on le
souhaiterait en termes d'innovation et
en terme peut-être de développement pour
un serment dans les entreprises que ce
soit des entreprises de grande taille
mais aussi pour des pme des hautes et y
donc c'était l'idée de faire un petit
peu le tour de tout ce qui peut y avoir
de très innovant très très pointues au
niveau de notre recherche de notation de
recherche de nos différentes structures
qui accompagnent la recherche et décide
de voir le lien qui lie avec les
vêtements l'innovation et le
développement d'un certain nombre de
process industriels et de conséquences
économiques des bienfaits économiques de
ceux de tous ses travaux faut qu'on
sache mieux financer
et avoir un capital très patient sûr si
vous voulez certaines innovations si on
parle du spatial du cantique de
l'hydrogène etc c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent pendant très
très longtemps avant d'avoir un retour
sur investissement on a beaucoup de
jeunes qui sont parfois si on sur des
projets très innovants qui présente un
réel intérêt économique mais ce qui est
compliqué c'est effectivement la
transformation là le passage à un modèle
économique viable
2022 c'est l'année de la jeunesse en
europe
je pense que c'est un message aussi pour
notre jeunesse européenne qui a besoin
d'espoir et je pense qu'on a des valeurs
à défendre
des valeurs européennes y compris dans
la recherche y compris dans les
applications de la recherche etc
[Musique]